bonjour Je me permets de vous appeler
j'ai consulté votre CV sur le site de la
PEC et aujourd'hui vos compétences
m'intéressent à travers un projet que
j'ai avec un de mes clients ce n'est pas
une agence d'intérim mais bien une
société de conseils en ingénierie
Renault Airbus Areva ou Alstom les
clients ce sont eux et aujourd'hui ils
passent tous par LR technologie pour
embaucher des ingénieurs sur des
missions spécifiques nous avons deux
types d'intervention
soit on positionne nos collaborateurs
LR technologie qui sont principalement
essus d'école d'ingénieur
ou soit nous faisons une recherche
spécifique pour nos clients afin de
répondre parfaitement à leurs besoins
les collaborateurs sont en réalité
directement employés en CDI par LR
technologie à la fin de leur mission qui
varie entre 6 et 18 mois la société les
enverra chez un autre client on est
poussé par nos clients à à faire une
forte croissance on est poussé par nos
collaborateurs à faire une forte
croissance c'est pour ça qu'en fait en
première année on est passé de 0 à 50
collaborateurs et là en 2è année on on
pense que notre atterissage on sera
environ une centaine de collaborateurs
dans les bureaux de LR technologie à
Versailles les recruteurs se
répartissent les différents secteurs
d'activité aéronautique spatiale défense
énergie ou industrie automobile et
ferroviaire la société a su s'imposer
sur un marché très concurrentiel avec un
chiffre d'affaires prévisionnel de 6
millions d'euros pour 2016 et l'objectif
d'atteindre les 100 millions en 2017